the jurogan experience it's crazy have
you seen that new movie everything
everywhere all at once no but i keep
hearing amazing things about it yeah we
just saw it this past uh did you go to
movie theater weekend yeah look at you
like a regular person yeah i like it
yeah how was it tell me what it's it's
it's a multiverse yeah kind of movie
it's like that there's
she uh
ends up figuring out how to um
uh switch into her different lives and
like take different times
uh different lives that she's lived
throughout all of time wait what the
[ __ ]
fast forward and rewind and use these
things to our advantage and try to
accomplish things it's crazy i love time
travel yeah it's wild
everything everywhere all at once you
know that was the that was the theory
that terence mckenna had to the thing
that's going to change the universe is
that one day someone's going to invent a
time machine and that when they invent a
time machine all time ceases to become
linear so you think if you have a time
machine well oh i'll just go back to the
time where they're making the pyramids
and i watch them do it
that's not what it works like what he
was saying you can't travel where there
are no roads so once a road gets built
then you can travel so once a time
machine gets invented then anyone from
the invention of the time machine
forward to forever can come back to that
moment and can go to any point in time
from that moment to the end of time so
all time ceases to be linear so there's
no like tomorrow will be wednesday and
the next day will be thursday no no it's
everything happens everywhere all at
once so people can travel back and forth
through time you can never own anything
because someone could just travel
through time and take it away from you
when you weren't looking like like as
time travel gets more and more
sophisticated you can go back and forth
in time while you're talking to people
you know if you don't like what you said
you could rewind and start all over
again if you're in an argument with your
wife you can go to the library and get
information and come back and go
actually you know herodotus once said
and then bam your wife thinks you're the
smartest guy in the world like
this but it would it would would there
would be no normal life anymore it would
like
the world itself would be completely
unrecognizable because time would mean
nothing you'd be able to travel back and
forth through time
all right so then so then
where would you go
right now just if i do we can time
travel right now go back in in the past
in the past what's one thing you'd like
to see again see that would be a
different kind of time travel that's an
unrealistic theatrical version of time
travel because like you said
once time is invented once time travel
is invented that's the time you can
start traveling so you can so you can't
go before that right so so like here we
are it's may of 2022. if time travel is
invented in june we're not going back to
april you can't go back to april okay
but you can go to from june to a million
years in the future and see what people
look like you'll be able to do that but
they'll be able to come back too and
everything's going to be happening
everywhere all at once there's not going
to be any sort of structure to life
there's not going to be anything in
terms of money possessions as long as
you can freely time travel there will be
no time everything's going to be moving
around and also instantaneously you'll
become immortal because whatever we have
right now in terms of technology what
we're going to have in a million years
is going to be god-like and you're going
to be able to travel to that if in fact
that actually does even take place
because the question becomes like what
is the future if time travel does exist
so if time travel exists in june of 2022
is there even a future like does it even
take place because how can anybody
invent things when they can just travel
to a point where someone invented it
already but how are they going to invent
it already if you can just travel to the
future and do they invent things still
or do people if they do invent things
how does what's to stop people from
going back before them and taking the
idea and introducing it before that thus
there'll be no intellectual property
because there'll be no way to say you
came up with it first it won't exist
carlos menci will be the greatest
comedian in the
world just smashing wow that think about
that is there someone working on timer
team right now there's got to be right
well there's a guy named ronald millette
i think he's out of the university of
connecticut if you google this and he's
got the craziest spider-man
character uh origin story
his father died and he became obsessed
with time travel because he wanted to go
back in time and save his father so he
became a professor
studying time travel and he came up with
a workable model of a time machine but
it requires immense immense power that's
him
ron millett built a device that
illustrates the principles he believes
could be used to build a time machine
but
he was one of the people that came up
with the first one of the first people
to come up with the real realization
or the revelation that once that time
machine was invented
from vietnam yeah
it's but it's i mean it is really like a
comic book
superhero sort of uh origin story isn't
it yeah it's a great origin story yeah
so this guy has become obsessed and he's
been working on it for decades
and they think they have
a working model of you know like at
least a theoretical model of a time
machine but it just requires
like the power of the sun
it requires immense power
i think there's a guy from
i think the early 19th century kurt
godel he wasn't from the early 19th
century early 20th century and he had a
working model of the time machine too
but it involved
something as large as like the solar
system like you you needed like a
machine the size of a solar system or
something something crazy
yeah
kirk odell in 1949 found a solution to
the field equations of general
relativity which described a space time
with some unusual properties this godel
universe permitted
closed time-like curves hence the
kind of time travel and it did not admit
decomposition into the successive
moments of time
yeah so he had i didn't understand any
of that sentence i mean like i'm so i'm
like so stupid that if i think if i
start to realize what that means it
gives me a panic attack
like as you talk about there's no
anything ever anywhere or when you just
mention the universe and i realize
there is
there is
there is something really up there like
there's no it's not just up there it's
out there yeah it's all around you that
i i don't like infinity
i'm that i [ __ ] gives me a panic
attack and immediately
yeah it'll give you a panic attack if
you if you really do stop and and give
it time and think about it's an amazing
thing
do you think that they'll be able to
take like i don't know if we have to go
to computer modeling but
uh
take the data of like this video for
instance where these kids are in 1901
and put that into like virtual reality
where you could then insert yourself
yeah to be in there you can't affect
anything but you could at least
experience and hear what it's like yeah
but you'll probably get an
interpretation of it like say if they
wanted to do that today and they had
this unbelievable ability to create
people and images and places and they
decided to show you the construction of
the pyramids they'll just be guessing